Transcriber: Sude Akgündoğdu
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Çok heyecanlıyım.
Doğal bir şey galiba.
Şimdi, bir haftadır, daha doğrusu
bir haftadan daha uzun bir süredir,
"Ya, ben ne anlatayım bu insanlara?"
diyordum. Elime kalem kağıt aldım dedim ki
"Tamam, çalışacağım." İnternetten
araştırma yapıyorum neler yapabilirim diye
Sonra bir baktım konseptimiz "An'lara
Tutunmak." Dedim ki ne yapıyorsun?
Bırak bakalım o kalemle kağıdı. Neyse,
ve dedim ki, konseptimize uygun davranayım
ve o an içimden gelsin, tamam. Bakın,
"an" diyoruz. Hatta demin size yaptığım
başlangıç geçmişte kaldı. Var ya Garavel
Usta bir zaman makinesi yapıyor, giriyor
içine, sonra tekrar çıkıyor, diyor ki:
"Bak Arif, dünden bugüne geldik," diye.
Tıpkı demin söylediğim şey gibi. Şimdi,
an... Hayatımda buraya gelmek için,
sizlerin karşısına çıkmak için, belki
birçok televizyon programı yapmış olmak
için, belki takımlarla çalışmak için, ne
oldu da hayat beni buraya getirdi,
nasıl bir an yaşadım hep düşündüm.
Ve ondan sonra ben şuna karar verdim
aslında, şu konuşmam sadece sizleri değil
beni de çok aydınlattı, çünkü ortada şöyle
bir durum vardı, dedim ki, "Herkes bir anı
bekliyor." Öyle bir an olsun ki..
İşte, loto çıksın, zengin olalım, köşeyi
dönelim. Ya da, biri bizi keşfetsin
ve hayatımızda daha başarılı olalım. Hep,
farkındaysanız, insan odak noktasında,
durduğu yerden başkalarının etkilerini
bekliyor. Ama sonra şunu farkettim, kendi
hayatımda "işte o an" dediğim bütün an-
larım, benim algılayış biçimimle alakalı.
Neyden mi bahsediyorum? Aslında şu görmüş
olduğunuz davulla kendimi çok iyi ifade
ettiğimi düşünüyorum. İlk önce sizin için
özel bir şey hazırladım, ve beni dinlerken
acaba size böyle daha mı iyi anlatabilirim
diye düşünüyorum.
Anlatmaya çalıştığım şey şu, kendinizi
nasıl değerlendiriyorsunuz? Şu an burada
olup başka işlerinizi yapamadığınızın
farkındasınız değil mi?
Çünkü şu an buradasınız. Neden?
Çünkü başka yapmanız gereken her şeyden
vazgeçtiniz, seçim yaptınız.
Çok güzel bir söz vardır:
"İnsan vazgeçebildiği kadar özgürdür."
Sonra gün oldu, hayatımı yaşamaya başladım
Ergenlik dönemlerinde, sizin yaşlarınızda.
Dediler ki bana: Davul hayatın ritmine
benzer. Hayatın ritmi bu.
Ve herkes bana "Serdar bunu yap," dedi.
Ondan sonra baktım, farklı bir şey yapmam
gerekiyordu, ama insanlar benden bunu
bekliyorlardı. Ben dedim ki hayır!
Ben böyle yapacağım. Hatta canım sıkıldı,
dedim ki, "böyle yapacağım."
Ama hepsi hayatın ritmiydi, sadece
farklıydı.
Sonra çalmaya başladım. Yaşadığımı
hissediyordum. Ve başka insanlar bana
dediler ki: "Çok abartıyorsun." Sonra
tekrar yakaladım hayatın ritmini.
Farkındaysanız üzerine giriyormuş gibi
oluyorum ama hiçbir zaman ritim
bozulmuyor. İşte algılayış biçimim, müziği
yaratıyor. İşte hayatımın ritmi.
Sonra bir baktım insanlar beni farklı
olmamdan rahatsız olmamaya başladılar.
Bakın meslek hayatım nasıl başladı
biliyor musunuz? Zamanında oynadığım
basketbol kulübünde, oradan emekli olduğum
zaman, Anadolu Efes - Barselona maçı.
Euro Lig'in bir şarkısı var ve o şarkıyı
çalmaya başladım. Sonra bunu internete
yükledim. Sonra beni Abdi İpekçi'nin
ortasına çıkardılar ve çalmaya başladım.
Kulüpler şunu sordu: "Ne iş yapıyorsun?"
Psikoloğum ben, dedim. Sonra ne dediler?
"Evet, bizim de sana ihtiyacımız var.
Hadi gel."
Gittim. Çalıştım. Benden daha iyi onlara
psikoloji anlatacak biri yok muydu? Vardı.
Ama ben bağlantılara çok önem veriyorum.
Bunu neden anlatıyorum? Çünkü o an!
Yani şu gördüğünüz şey var ya, hep
çevremde arkadaşlarım, ailem dedi ki
boşu boşuna çalıyorsun, boşu boşuna
yapıyorsun dedi. Hayır, dedim, o bana bir
gün anımı yakalatacak. Oradan başladım
Beşiktaş Kulübü'ne, başka bir büyük kulübe
televizyon kanallarına, sonra bir baktım
farklı olduğum için dikkat çekiyorum.
Ama bunun için uğraşmamak gerekiyormuş,
sonra bunu anladım.
Aslında şu an burada olmamın sebebi bu.
Evet ben uzman klinik psikoloğum.
İsmim Serdar, soy adım Vatansever.
Ama benim başka bir kimliğim daha var.
Size kendimi daha rahat ifade etmek için
kullandığım bir kimlik. İşte bu yüzden
sizin şunu bilmenizi istiyorum. Ben kendi
hayatımda vazgeçildiğim kadar özgürdüm.
Ve anlarımı gördüm. İşte o an dediğim
anlarınız şu anda buralarda, tamam mı?
Ve büyük ihtimalle bu odadan çıkınca,
bu salondan çıkınca, siz de bir şeyleri
doğru fark ederseniz neyi nasıl
kullanacağınızı bileceksiniz.
Ben keyif aldığım şeyleri yaptığım için
hem sizin karşınızdayım hemde çalışmıyorum
Çok güzel bir laf var, diyor ki, "Eğer
işini seversen hayatın boyunca çalışmazsın
Ben hayatım boyunca o anları
değerlendirmek için vardım.
Tıpkı şu anki gibi.
Şu an bir an yaşıyoruz, ve yaklaşık 7-8
dakikayı geride bıraktık.
Ama şunu bilmek lazım,
bunun ana maddesi şu,
bizler, yakaladığımız anları acaba
değerlendirebiliyor muyuz?
Algılayabiliyor muyuz?
Herkesin bir kırılma anı vardır.
Ben danışanlarımla bu anı seans odalarında
yaşarım. Sizce, bir insan kendi kırılma
anını fark ederse mi, yoksa fark etmezse
mi daha şanslı olur?
Tabii ki fark ederse! Neden?
Çünkü bizler kendimizi algılayış
biçimimize göre yaşıyoruz.
Ve hani o özgüven denilen şey var ya?
Kendinizi algılayış biçiminiz aslında.
İşte aslında hepinizin hayatında
bir an var.
O anları şu salondan çıkınca bir
düşünmenizi istiyorum.
İlla size peak yaptırıp yukarıya
taşıyan anlar değil.
Sizi çat diye aşağı düşüren anlardan da
bahsediyorum, atlamayın bunları.
Neden? Çünkü ben hep danışanlarıma
bunu örnek veriyorum.
Eğer havuzun ortasındaysan, ve yukarıya
çıkmaya çalışıyorsan yorulmuşsundur.
Çıkamıyorsundur. Yapman gereken şey ne?
Kendini daha da dibe batırmak.
Neden? Çünkü bir dip var.
O dibe basıp kendini daha rahat
yukarıya atabilirsin.
İşte bizler her zaman daha iyi olmaya
çalışıyoruz ya, işte ben farklı omakla
daha kötü olmanın riskini aldım.
Ve bu yüzden hayatımdaki anları daha
iyi algılayabildim.
İşte belki de sizin karşınızda,
tesadüflerle dolu bir hayattan bu
kırmızı halının ortasına geldim.
Bu yüzden ben hayatımda kendimi ifade
edebileceğim bir yol buldum.
Sizlerin de kendinizi ifade edeceğiniz
bir yol bulmasını isterim.
Anları yakalayabilmek için onları iyi
algılayabilmek lazım.
Çünkü eğer onları algılayabilirseniz,
ne olacak? Onlara göre hareket edip
kendinize daha fazla saygınız olacak.
Bu kadar basit.
Bir de şundan bahsedeyim.
Bu beni çok etkiler.
Şimdi karşıma biri oturur ve der ki,
"Hocam, ben kız arkadaşımla tartıştım.
Ve ayrıldık. O kadar üzgünüm, o kadar
şanssızım ki!" Tamam.
Ben şunu sorarım karşı tarafa,
"Hadi gel kendini şöyle değerlendir.
Bir, sen kız arkadaşından ayrılan,
ilişkisini yürütemeyen, ve kendi
karakterini yetersiz bulduğu için o
karşıdaki kişinin seni terk ettiğini
düşünen biri misin? Yoksa, ikinizin
frekansının farklı olabileceğini düşünen
bir birey misin?
Sizce ilki mi, ikincisi mi kendine
daha çok saygı duyar?
İkincisi.
Neden? Çünkü kendini yetersiz görmedi de
ondan. İşte bu insan eğer kendine
bakabiliyorsa, eğer savunma mekanizmaları
buna el veriyorsa o zaman hayatındaki
anları da doğru yakalayacak demektir.
Bu yüzden ana tutunmak konsepti benim
çok hoşuma gitti.
Ama ilk başta dediğim şeyleri unutmayın.
Hayatın size bir şeyler sunması için sizin
çabalamanız gerekiyor.
Neden biliyor musunuz?
Çünkü şans çabayı sever.
Biz hep şikayet ederiz, bu Türk
filmlerinden bizim kültürümüze geçmiş
bir şey. Daha doğrusu bizim kültürümüzden
dolayı Türk filmleri oluşmuş, öyle diyelim
Orada dikkatimi çeken şeylerden biri,
her zaman bir şey olsun ve bizi yukarıya
atsın diye bekleriz.
İşte, yukarıya gitmemiz için aslında o
şeyler hep var. Bunu hepinizin hayatından
bahsediyorum. Spor yapanınız varsa,
nereden nereye geldiğinizi ve hangi anda
geldiğinizi, bırakacağın zaman neden
başladığını düşünüp, hep o anları hatırla.
Çünkü anlar, her zaman bizim bayrak
diktiğimiz yerler.
Hayatımız bir yol olsun, ve bu yolda
ilerlerken, ve zikzaklı bir yol iken bu,
o anlara bayrak dikmek, geriye dönüp
baktığınızda nasıl bir hayat yaşadığınızı
size daha iyi ifade edecek.
Geçmişi bilmek çok önemli! Neden?
Çünkü, o gördüğünüz bayraklar var ya,
kendinize olan saygınız demek oluyor.
İşte bu yüzden anlara tutunmak önemli.
Bunu düz bir yol gibi düşünmeyin.
Bunu dağa tırmanıyormuş gibi düşünün.
Ve her anınızda çıktığınız yere bir çivi
çaktığınız gibi hayal edin.
O zaman düşmeyeceksiniz. Neden?
Çünkü tutunacak çok şeyiniz olacak.
Bana göre, benim bu arkadaşla tanışmam
bir şans. Bana göre o sahanın ortasına
gittiğim zaman, eskiden oynadığım takımın
bana gelip, "Hocam, ne iş yapıyorsunuz?"
demesi bir şans. İşte bu yüzden ben bazen
şöyle değerlendiriyorum, diyorum ki,
"Serdar, eğer sen, davul çalıp ellerini
yıkayıp o koridordan geçmeseydin,
ellerini yıkamasaydın, o zaman o adamlarla
karşılaşmayacaktın. Çünkü tam o koridorun
köşesinde karşılaştık.
Kelebek etkisi gibi bir şey.
Tamam, bu çok çekici, ve çok film gibi
ama yetersiz.
Benliğimi pasifleştirdiğini gördüm bu ana
tutunmanın. Benliğimi pasifleştiriyordu.
Yani, bir şey var, ve o bir şey beni orada
yükseltti diyordum. Hayır.
Orada, algılayış biçimim...
Ne dedim? Şans çabayı sever.
Şans çabayı sevdiği için ben çabaladım.
Mesela geldi birisi, televizyon programı
yapalım dedi.
"Yaparım," dedim.
Dergiye yazı yaz, dedi.
"Yazarım," dedim.
Çok değerlidir.
Yani, diyeceğim o ki, bizler farklı
olmaktan da korkmayacağız arkadaşlar.
Farklı olmak, şöyle bir şey. Eğer farklı
olmak istiyorsanız farklı bir iş
yapmayacaksınız. Buraya gelip böyle deli
gibi koştura da bilirdim, belki dikkat
çekerdim. Ama yaptığım işi farklı bir
şekilde yapmak için bunu getirdim buraya.
Sizlere farklı ifade etmek için.
İşte o yüzden hayatınızda farklı olmaktan
korkmazsanız, o zaman anlarınıza
daha çok tutunabileceksiniz, benliğinizden
düşmemek için.
Benliğiniz bir dağ.
Anlara tutunmak, o yaşadığınız anlar,
oraya tutunmak için vurduğunuz her çivi,
sizi o dağda daha sağlam tutacak.
Bu yüzden genç beyinlerinizi, yaptığınız
işi farklılaştırarak değil,yapış şeklinizi
farklılaştırmaya odaklayın.
Bu cümlem anlaşıldı mı?
Doğru mu kurdum acaba diye düşündüm.
Yapacağınız şekli farklılaştıracaksınız.
Çünkü, çok büyük risk aldım.
Bana dediler ki, "Serdar kurma davulu ya!"
"Neden?" dedim,
"Afallayabilirsin."
Dedim ki, "Ben bundan önce hep afalladım
zaten." İnternete girin bakın, padişah
kostümleriyle çaldığım müzikler var.
Girin bakın, işte, subay kostümüyle
çaldığım müzikler var.
Batman kostümüyle çaldığım müzikler var.
Sosyal deneyler yapıyorum.
"Psikolog ne yapmaz?" diye videolar
çekiyorum. Çok da güzel rakamlarda
izleniyor. Ama bunun sebebi ne?
Ben risk aldım. Benim yerimdeki başka biri
risk alamaz, neden alamadı, çünkü
kaygıları var. Kaygıları neden?
Mesleki duruşundan belki.
Belki bu mesleği yapış, yani psikolog oluş
biçimini kendi kafasında sadece belli bir
noktaya oturtuşundandır.
Ama sizler bir şeyi farklı yapıyorsanız,
belki o işi çok iyi biliyorsunuz
demektir de.
Çünkü çok güzel bir laf var. Der ki:
Lafı unutur muşum bir de böyle yaparken...
"Eğer bir şeyi çok iyi biliyorsan,
basit yapabilirsin.
Ve metafor kullanabilirsin."
Demin size bir benzetme kullandım,
benliğinizle alakalı, o dağ oluşundan.
İşte, şuan o dağın başında olabilirsiniz.
Bunun zamanla hiçbir alakası yok.
Benim yaşımı bilseniz, şaşırırsınız.
Benim yaşımda mezun olamayan
arkadaşlarım var.
Ben şuan devlet kanalında programımı da
yaptım. Dergilerde yazımızı da yazdım.
Ya da şu an kliniğimde, 5-6 odalı
kliniğimde, kendi odamda,
arka tarafta, bir film stüdyom var,
bir de müzik stüdyom var.
Neden?
Hatta insanlar şey diyor,
"Hocam ne yapmışsın burayı?"
Diyorum, "At koşturuyorum. Konsol oyun
oynuyorum arkada mesela." Neden?
Çünkü hayata ben bu şekilde tutunuyorum.
Anlarımı bu şekilde yaratıyorum.
İşte sizlerin de bu konuda anlarınıza
tutunmak için size bugün yeni bir gözlük
veriyorum. Farklı bir gözlük bu.
Hatta ben de, bir şekilde, kendi anımı
burada sizlerle birlikte yakalıyorum.
Bitirmeden... Sizlerin yüzüne
bakarken hep şunu algılıyorum.
Korku.
Gelecekle alakalı korku.
İşte demin o bahsettiğim bütün
anlar var ya? Size geleceğinize daha iyi
saldırabilmek, daha iyi gidebilmekle
alakalı belinizi daha iyi kuşatacak.
Neden?
Bunun bir savaş olduğuna asla inanmıyorum
ama,bu savaşta ne kadar donanımınız olursa
o kadar rahat hissedeceksiniz kendinizi.
İşte bu donanımı elde etmek için, anlara
tutunmak gerekiyor. Yaşadığınız anlara
kendinize yaşattığınız anlara.
Bana hayatım boyunca dediler ki:
Yapma, etme, çalma...
Çalma derken yani, aleti çalma.
Yanlış anlamayın.
Ben de dedim ki, hep bu cümleye göre
yaşadım hayatımı,
sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum:
Müziği duymayanlar,
dans edenleri deli zannederler.
Ben bir deliyim.
Teşekkür ederim.